vous avez regardé à 10h28 vous le savez
bernard montiel apprécie énormément tous
les chroniqueurs ne touche pas à mon
poste
enfin sauf alors il était chez jean marc
morandini elle a regardé le replay dur
mercredi et bernard il est ni bon
camarade mais il a un petit problème
avec une personne autour
sachez que l état une place de lui sur
sa gauche regardez cyril parce qu'alors
vraiment d'abord c'est du direct une
spontanéité incroyable
le mec il a mille idées à leurs
benjamins c'est mon copain on a
travaillé ensemble sur tf1 on a vécu des
choses ensemble s'est trouvée julien
sincèrement l'a dit d'ailleurs une
émission formidable dans capital de
leurs mots je le connais très peu et
c'est vrai que je cherche pas le
connaître plus on pouvait espérer vous
voir dans son émission people de leurs
mots le vendredi vous n'y êtes pas alors
non je n'ai pas voulu y aller
franchement j'avais refusé
oui c'est pas voulu la faire parce que
déjà si je suis là tous les soirs je ne
veux pas y être en plus le vendredi donc
si c'était un autre soir vous l'auriez
fait non de toute façon
[Applaudissements]
jamais donc vous ne le connaissez pas
trop si vous n'avez pas envie de plus de
connaître non non pourquoi rang des
collègues de travail mémoire on ne
connaît vraiment envie de connaître
d'autres gens on voulait juste non non
vous avez assez d'amis mois d'une prime
au moins vous non non rien de méchant si
je serais heureux d'être là la tient à
nicolas qui a vu en entier
parce que là évidemment foyers non mais
rien de méchant ah oui et oui il n'a pas
envie de faire plus ample connaissance
laisser honnête que c'est vrai sélection
d'appareils de me connaître non ah ben
moi j'ai aucun souci avec toi moi je dis
je ne méprise pas les gens dont je ne
connais pas ce qui visiblement payé car
pas mépriser qu'ils se rassurent les
missions du pôle on lui a pas proposé
donc
[Applaudissements]
du poème c'est souvent les gens que l'on
cap une actu faut qu'ils cherchent à
faire du bain
jamais répond à ce qu'il vienne à quoi
alors il est où reposait le fallait on
lui a proposé c'est faux je suis
producteur d'émissions la procédure
proposée salle et ça n'avait pas été
validé par mathieu a dit d'arrêter de
bienvenue mais ça ne vois pas trop
l'intérêt comme ça d'elle et d'aller
[ __ ] un peu la merde c'est beau parce
que il est vexé son ego n'a pris un coup
et se venge bassement vous vivent mieux
il est sincère parce qu'en logis dit
clairement qui peut pas vous blesser ou
tuer le football féminin a toutefois
laissé bon genre
allez allez
[Musique]
bonjour
à l'est les chéris mais faut pas le
chercher à nous mathieu et tu pars
plairait moi on me vole mon jean puech
t'adore thé chaud ou toi t'es pas faux
culs n'est pas faux culs